WE WILL SEE TOMORROW NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
CHRISTMAS IS ALMOST HERE, THE
BEST WEEK ON THE AMERICAN
CALENDAR, THE HAPPIEST TIME THAT
WE HAVE.
THIS YEAR, OF ALL YEARS,
CHRISTMAS HAS A DEEPER WAY TO BE
CLOSER TO ITS ORIGINAL MEANING.
IN A TIME OF CRISIS, YOU THINK
OF THE THINGS YOU MIGHT
OTHERWISE IGNORE IF YOU ARE
BUSIER AND MORE CONTENT, THINGS
LIKE, WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF ALL
OF THIS?
WHAT MATTERS MOST IN MY LIFE?
AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT ENDS?
IN GENERAL, PEOPLE TEND TO
BECOME MORE SPIRITUAL, MORE
OPENLY RELIGIOUS, WHEN THEY ARE
SUFFERING.
THAT IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
IN FACT, IT MAY BE THE UPSIDE,
TO THINK BEYOND THE NEXT AMAZON
DELIVERY FOR A MINUTE.
OF COURSE, NOT EVERYONE IS IN
FAVOR OF THAT.
ALL OF THE FOCUS ON THE BIG, AND
DOING THINGS, FOCUS ON THE
FAMILY, FOCUS ON WHAT IS TRUE
AND WHAT IS NOT TRUE, THE FOCUS
ON ETERNITY ITSELF, ALL OF THAT
TENDS TO DIMINISH THE POWER OF
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF OUR
TEMPORAL WORLD.
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS.
WE TAKE OUR LEADERS LESS
SERIOUSLY WHEN WE ARE REMINDED
THAT THEY ARE JUST PEOPLE.
SLIGHTLY LUDICROUS, JUST LIKE WE
ARE.
WHEN WE ARE REMINDED THAT THEY
TOO WILL PASS, ALL OF US WILL.
IF DEATH IS INEVITABLE -- THAT
MAY BE THE ONE THING YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THIS COUNTRY,
BUT IT IS STILL TRUE -- THEN
MAYBE WE SHOULD PAUSE BEFORE WE
DESTROY THE LIVING AND THE NAME
OF TRYING TO ELIMINATE IT.
POLITICIANS UNDERSTAND THIS
THREAT.
THEY’VE FIGURED OUT THAT
CHRISTMAS IS BIGGER THAN THEY
ARE, AND THEREFORE, IT IS A
THREAT TO THEM.
BETTER CANCEL IT.
IN FACT, THEY ARE TRYING HARD.
>> MINIMIZING TRAVEL TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE.
SOMETIMES, IT’S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY, BUT TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE, DON’T TRAVEL, DON’T
CONGREGATE TOGETHER.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THAT IS,
RIGHT NOW, THEY JUST SHOULD NOT
BE DONE.
TO THE BEST OF OUR CAPABILITIES,
WE SHOULD AVOID TRAVEL AND AVOID
CONGREGATE.
>> Tucker: AVOID CONGREGATE
SETTINGS.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT TONY
FAUCI, HE HAS MASTERED, AFTER
MANY DECADES, THE WEIRD
EUPHEMISMS OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHAT FAUCI IS SAYING HERE IN
ENGLISH IS YOU NEED TO AVOID
GOING TO CHURCH, YOU NEED TO
AVOID YOUR OWN FAMILY.
THOSE ARE THE CONGREGATE
SETTINGS HE JUST MENTIONED.
YOU NEED TO SPEND CHRISTMAS
ALONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
ALL THE EXPERTS AGREE WITH THAT.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
SAID THAT VERY MESSAGE THIS
WEEK.
THE CDC’S INCIDENT MANAGER, A
MAN CALLED DR. HENRY WALKIE,
DECLARED THAT "THE BEST THING
FOR AMERICANS TO DO IN THE
UPCOMING HOLIDAY SEASON IS TO
STAY AT HOME AND NOT TRAVEL."
SO, SKIPPING CHRISTMAS IS THE
BEST THING, SAYS DR. WALKIE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT HE IS A
PRODUCT OF THE JOHNS HOPKINS
BLOOMBERG SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND THOSE, YOU MAY
REMEMBER, THE PEOPLE WHO JUST
THIS SUMMER WERE PUBLICLY
ENCOURAGING BLM TO RIOT IN OUR
CITIES, ON MEDICAL GROUNDS,
NEEDLESS TO SAY.
ONE SENIOR SCHOLAR AT THE
BLOOMBERG SCHOOL OF HEALTH,
IDENTIFIED AS DR. JENNIFER KNEW
SO, DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE AN
ACTUAL DECISION BUT BOASTS SHE
IS A CLIMATE ACTIVIST,
TWEETED THIS MEMORABLE PIECE OF
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL GUIDANCE BACK
IN EARLY JUNE.
HERE IT IS, "IN THIS MOMENT, THE
PUBLIC HEALTH RISK OF NOT
PROTESTING TO DEMAND AN END TO
SYSTEMIC RACISM GREATLY EXCEED
THE HARMS OF THE VIRUS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IN HER STUDIED
EXPERT MEDICAL OPINION, NOT
INCLUDING MACY’S, FAILING TO
BURN DOWN BUSINESSES YOU DON’T
OWN, IS ACTUALLY MORE DANGEROUS
THAN GETTING THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOW, YOU ARE A CIVILIAN, THAT
MIGHT SOUND CRAZY TO YOU, BUT
AGAIN, YOU ARE NOT AN
EPIDEMIOLOGYEPIDEMIOLOGIST.
THEY KNOW BETTER.
THE FORMER HEAD OF THE CDC
HIMSELF, DR. TOM FRIEDMAN,
ENDORSE THAT GUIDANCE.
THERE IS A CONSENSUS, ALL OF THE
EXPERTS AGREE.
THE THINGS THAT THEY LIKE ARE
PERFECTLY SAFE, INDEED
ENCOURAGED, BUT THE THINGS THEY
DON’T LIKE ARE DEADLY.
CATASTROPHIC, IN FACT.
LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN EXPLAIN HOW
MANY AMERICANS WILL DIE IF WE
DON’T CANCEL CHRISTMAS.
>> WE ARE LIKELY TO LOSE ANOTHER
250,000 PEOPLE, DEAD, BETWEEN
NOW AND JANUARY.
YOU HEAR ME?
BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN’T PAYING
ATTENTION.
>> Tucker: YOU HEAR ME?
250,000 AMERICANS DEAD.
YOU HEAR ME?
A QUARTER MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT IS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IN FACT, THAT’S MORE THAN THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF COMBAT DEATHS
OVER THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
CIVIL WAR.
WHICH, BY THE WAY, LASTED FOR
YEARS, CONDENSED INTO A SINGLE
MONTH.
IMAGINE A GETTYSBURG EVERY DAY
OF THE WEEK.
YOU CAN’T IMAGINE THAT, IT IS
TOO HORRIBLE.
IN THE FIRST 30 DAYS, WE WOULD
LOSE THE EQUIVALENT OF RENO.
THE NEXT MONTH, SCOTTSDALE, THEN
LOVE IT, THEN BUFFALO.
PRETTY SOON, THERE WOULD BE
NOBODY LEFT IN AMERICA.
DO YOU HEAR ME?
COME ON, MEN!
DO WHAT YOU ARE TOLD!
CANCEL CHRISTMAS!
OR AT LEAST STOP WALKING.
WALKING IS NOW AN UNPATRIOTIC
ACT, SO IS BICYCLING AND ANY
CONTACT WITH WHEELED VEHICLES,
THAT IS THE WORD FROM
LOS ANGELES.
LOS ANGELES, OUR SECOND LARGEST
CITY, HAS JUST ISSUED A NEW
COROLLA LAW.
IT BANS "ALL TRAVEL," INCLUDING
"TRAVEL ON FOOT, BICYCLE,
SCOOTER, AUTOMOBILE, PUBLIC
TRANSIT."
ALL OF IT.
IN LOS ANGELES, MOVEMENT ITSELF
IS NOW ILLEGAL.
SORRY, KIDS, PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
INTERNAL PASSPORTS ARE ON THE
WAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, YOU HAVE
NETFLIX, SO STOP COMPLAINING.
IN CASE YOU ARE CONFUSED BY THIS
GUIDANCE, ERIC HE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE IT SIMPLE FOR YOU.
ERIC GARCETTI IS THE MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES, THAT IS HIS TITLE,
BUT OVER HIS YEARS IN OFFICE,
HIS ROLE HAS GROWN, AND HE
WIELDS POWER WE WANT --
ERIC GARCETTI MAY SEEM LIKE A
GARDEN-VARIETY ELECTED OFFICIAL,
OILY, INCOMPETENT, NOT YET 50
YEARS OLD, BUT THAT IS AN
ILLUSION.
IN FACT, ERIC GARCETTI IS
OMNIPOTENT.
WATCH.
>> MY MESSAGE COULDN’T BE
SIMPLER.
IT IS TIME TO HUNKER DOWN.
IT IS TIME TO CANCEL EVERYTHING.
AND IF IT ISN’T ESSENTIAL, DON’T
DO IT.
DON’T MEET UP WITH OTHERS
OUTSIDE YOUR HOUSEHOLD.
DON’T HOST THAT GATHERING.
DON’T ATTEND A GATHERING.
>> Tucker: IT’S TIME TO CANCEL
EVERYTHING, COMMANDS LORD
GARCETTI.
WHEN HE SAYS EVERYTHING, HE
MEANS EVERYTHING.
UP TO AND INCLUDING YOUR MOST
SACRED HOLIDAY, TIME WITH YOUR
FAMILY, THE ILLUSION OF FREE
WILL IN ITSELF.
YOU WERE A CITIZEN, NOW YOU ARE
A SUPPLICANT.
ALL IT TOOK WAS A SINGLE
SENTENCE FROM ERIC MICHAEL
GARCETTI.
LONDON BREED UNDERSTOOD THAT
VERY EARLY, THE MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO, ELECTED ON THE
STRENGTH OF HER FASCINATING
NAME, SHE HAS NO OTHER OBVIOUS
QUALIFICATION.
ON OCTOBER 30TH THIS YEAR,
LONDON BREED DECLARE THE
HOLIDAYS ARE SUPER SPREADER
EVENTS, DELIVER THE SAD NEWS
THAT WE CAN’T CELEBRATE
ANYTHING.
>> WHAT WE HAVE SEEN DURING
HOLIDAYS, SADLY, IS AN UPTICK IN
THE NUMBER OF CASES BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING TO COME
TOGETHER, AND SOMETIMES, THESE
PARTIES AND THESE EVENTS AND
THESE GATHERINGS, THEY CAN
BECOME SUPER-SPREADER’S.
IT JUST TAKES ONE PERSON WHO IS
INFECTED TO INFECT, YOU KNOW,
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED A
PARTY.
EVEN THOUGH THIS YEAR WILL BE A
SACRIFICE, THE SACRIFICE IS
WORTH IT.
>> Tucker: THE SACRIFICE IS
WORTH IT, SAYS LONDON BREED.
NOW, YOUR SACRIFICE, TO BE YOUR
MORE SPECIFIC, NOT HER
SACRIFICE.
JUST EIGHT DAYS AFTER MAKING THE
DECLARATION YOU JUST SAW, LONDON
BREED WAS TRAVELING DOWN SOME OF
THE WORLD’S MOST EXPENSIVE FOOD
AT THE FRENCH RESTAURANT IN
NAPA, GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM MODE
BREED IS TERRIFIED OF THE DIRE
PANDEMIC WE ARE LIVING THROUGH,
SACRIFICING FOR, BUT NOT SO
CONCERNED SHE IS WILLING TO
ENDURE ANY PERSONAL
INCONVENIENCE, NO MATTER HOW
SMALL IT MIGHT BE.
NO CHRISTMAS FOR YOU, BUT LONDON
BREED HAS GOT TO EAT.
RIGHT NOW, LONDON BREED IS IN
THE ROOT FOR CELERY ROOT,
FOLLOWED BY THE STAKE RIVER
FARM,.
B SACRIFICE IS WORTH IT.
STEVE ADLER UNDERSTAND
SACRIFICE, HE IS THE MAYOR OF
AUSTIN, TEXAS.
A GREAT PLACE, A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE MOVING THERE, ONE OF THE
MOST CHARMING CITIES THAT WE
HAVE.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO AUSTIN
RECENTLY, YOU MAY NOTICE HUGE
NUMBERS OF MENTALLY ILL DRUG
ADDICTS CRAPPING ON THE SIDEWALK
AND STEALING THINGS ON MUGGING
PEOPLE.
STEVE EITHER DID THAT.
STEVE ADLER WANTS TO MAKE
AUSTIN, TEXAS, MOST WELCOMING TO
THE PEOPLE WELCOMED LEAST.
HE IS ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SO WORRIED THAT STEVE ADLER HAS
COMMANDED HIS CONSTITUENTS TO
STAY HOME FOR THE DURATION.
HE INFORMED THEM THIS FROM A
TIME-SHARE IN A MEXICAN BEACH
RESORTS.
HE HAD FLOWN THERE SECRETLY ON A
PRIVATE PLANE WITH PEOPLE HE IS
NOT RELATED TO.
SOUNDS FUN, BUT DON’T TRY IT
YOURSELF, STEVE ADLER MIGHT
PUNISH YOU.
HERE HE IS.
>> WE NEED TO, YOU KNOW, STAY
HOME, IF YOU CAN, DO EVERYTHING
YOU CAN TO TRY TO KEEP THE
NUMBERS DOWN.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO RELAX.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
UNLESS YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE A
PRIVATE PLANE HEADED TO CABO.
OTHERWISE, STAY HOME!
THAT WAS MAYOR STEVE ADLER’S
MESSAGE TO HIS PEOPLE DELIVERED
FROM THE MEXICAN BEACH RESORT.
SO, WHAT DO WE TAKE FROM ALL OF
THIS?
WELL, IT IS HYPOCRISY, OF
COURSE.
WE POINT THAT OUT A LOT.
BUT IT IS DEEPER THAN THAT.
THE PEOPLE GIVING US THESE HIGH
LEASES ORDERS DON’T BELIEVE THE
ORDERS.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING, OBVIOUSLY, THEY DON’T
REALLY THINK COVID-19 IS VERY
DANGEROUS.
IF THEY THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
DANGEROUS, THEY WOULD BE
FOLLOWING THEIR OWN ORDERS.
OF COURSE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWING THEIR
OWN ORDERS.
NANCY PELOSI AND
DIANNE FEINSTEIN, FOR EXAMPLE,
ARE BOTH OVER 80 YEARS OLD, THEY
ARE THE TARGET DEMO, THEY ARE AT
RISK.
AND YET WE KNOW BECAUSE IT IS ON
VIDEO THAT NEITHER ONE IS SO
WORRIED ABOUT COVID-19 THAT SHE
WEARS MASKS IN PRIVATE.
SO, WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
EVEN SLOW PEOPLE LIKE US ARE
STARTING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
LAST NIGHT, THERE WAS A
DEMONSTRATION OUTSIDE OF A BAR
IN NEW YORK CALLED MAX PUBLIC
HOUSE.
NO CASES OF CORONAVIRUS HAVE
BEEN TRACED TO MAX PUBLIC HOUSE.
IT IS NOT A PROVEN VECTOR OF
TRANSMISSION FROM AS
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS SAY.
THE OWNER OF THE BAR REFUSED TO
SHUT DOWN.
HE WANTED TO LIVE LIKE
GAVIN NEWSOM AND LONDON BREED
AND NANCY PELOSI.
HE WANTED TO LIVE LIKE AN ADULT
IN AMERICA.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM, HE
EXPRESSED THESE VIEWS OUT LOUD
ON TELEVISION, IN FACT, AND THAT
IS DEFINITELY NOT ALLOWED, SO
THEY ARRESTED HIM IMMEDIATELY,
AND WHEN THEY DID, A CROWD OF
PEOPLE DECIDED THEY HAD HAD
ENOUGH.
[INDISTINCT CHANTING]
>> Tucker: YOU SHOULD KNOW
THAT NO ONE FROM THE CDC OR THE
JOHNS HOPKINS BLOOMBERG SCHOOL
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ENDORSED THE
PROTEST YOU JUST SAW.
IT WAS THE WRONG VARIETY OF
POLITICS, AND THEREFORE, IT WAS
A SERIOUS HEALTH RISK TO THE
NATION.
NOT ENOUGH VANDALISM COME
APPARENTLY.
BUT WE CAN EXPECT MORE PROTEST
LIKE IT PURELY YESTERDAY, A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN INTERRUPTED A
LIVE SHOT ON LOCAL TELEVISION TO
INCREASINGLY OBVIOUS OBSERVATION
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
IT’S THIS.
THE EFFECTS OF THESE LOCKDOWNS,
THE SACRIFICES WE ARE BEING
ASKED TO MAKE, ARE NOT EVENLY
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
CERTAIN PEOPLE, A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE, SEEM HAPPIER THAN EVER.
YOU NOTICE A CERTAIN
SELF-SATISFIED JAUNTY NEST
BEHIND THEIR MASKS, AS THEY BARK
ORDERS AT YOU.
BUT EVERYONE ELSE IS DYING A
SLOW DEATH.
DAVE MORRIS JOINS US IN A MINUTE
TO ELABORATE ON THIS POINT, BUT
UNTIL THEN, ONE MORE QUESTION
ABOUT ALL OF US.
AND AGAIN, IT IS AN OBVIOUS ONE
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE DO.
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
IF LOCKDOWNS WORK, WHY HAVEN’T
THEY WORKED SO FAR?
WE’VE BEEN FOLLOWING
INCREASINGLY SPECIFIC ORDERS ALL
YEAR.
DON’T TRAVEL, WEAR MASKS, SOME
PEOPLE HAVEN’T OBEYED, BUT AN
AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE.
MOST PEOPLE, BECAUSE IT IS
AMERICA, AND PEOPLE WANT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
AND YET, AFTER ALMOST A YEAR OF
THIS, THE NUMBERS KEEP RISING.
SO IS THE LESSON REALLY THAT WE
NEED A WHOLE LOT MORE OF WHAT